Trying some ice cream today.
I love a good homemade ice cream,
but we got sent some ice cream,
so might as well try it. These are all the flavours we're working with.
What do we get started with?
Trozen fudge. It's vegan.
Trozen fudge. Let's do it.
Oh, okay.
Smells like cinnamon.
Do you smell like ice? Does it? How does ice smell?
Cheers.
Wait, no, you gotta make a noise.
Not my cup of tea. I like this one.
You do? I like it.
Rate it.
I don't know yet. Chocolate is too strong to me.
I don't really like chocolate,
so that wasn't the vibe for me.
What I'm most excited about is the Earl Grey one.
I rate that ice cream a four out of 10.
Earl Grey.
Try this. Gorgeous.
What's this one? Earl Grey.
What's Earl Grey? A tea.
Mmm.
That is so floral. Fragrant.
Holy crap.
Even feel like the ice cream flavor you would like giving dirt.
I'm kidding. No,
I like it. It's okay.
I like it. Would you rate it?
I like it.
Okay. I rate the troll and fudge.
It's at a solid eight right now.
This is a 5. A 5?
I rate this an 8. It's so good.
Then we have cranberry and cheesecake.
I hope I'm pronouncing that right.
This is what we're working with.
Good swirl in there. Chunks of cheesecake.
I've actually never had a cheesecake.
I think. Don't know if.
I'm not that I remember. What is this
one? Out of 10?
Cookies and cream caramel swirl.
Now, this one,
I'm so freaking excited to try.
Wow. I'm so excited.
You washing my spoon for me?
Yeah. Thanks, honey.
Here you go. I appreciate that.
Hmm.
Stunning
strawberry shortcake. Oh, okay.
It looks pretty. I might change my opinion.
This hot stuff. Oh.
I don't know if I'm gonna like this one.
Yeah, I saw it,
and I thought that.
Mmm. I stand corrected.
Wow. It's actually.
That's stunning. It's actually really good.
An 8.5,
7.26. About the up to nine.
I think I'm gonna like this one.
Brown sugar chunk with cookie dough and brownies. This is our last one.
This is what we're working with.
Scooping ice cream is so hard for me.
Sometimes it's a 9. It's a 9.
And that, to me,
is a 7.
I love how rich and luscious the ice cream is.
Of all of these, they're so creamy,
so good. My top favorite one was the strawberry shortcake.
I don't know what it was about it.
Look how stunning it looks.
What was yours? The churro and fudge. Yes.